So, is showing the NP completeness of a problem always so involved with playing around
with strange constructions such as weird networks?
Well, the answer is in a way yes.
Showing NP completeness can often involve playing around a lot
and some gory details in the proofs.
So, even today, there are still scientific papers being published that
basically just show the NP completeness of a certain problem or set of problems.
So, it is not an easy task, but luckily,
there is a whole arsenal of known NP complete problems
out there which I'm now going to show you.
If you go on Wikipedia, for example,
there is a whole list of NP complete problems
from graph theory,  network design, sets and partitions, and so on and so on.
So, for most practical problems that you will encounter
either they have already been shown to be NP complete
or although likely be very similar to one or more of these problems
for which we already know that they are NP  complete.
In this case, similarity is a good thing because similarity means that a reduction will,
in most cases, be either much easier than what we have just seen with shortest tour or,
at least, if you then look at the NP completeness proofs for those problems,
then I give you techniques and ideas for performing the reduction that you are looking for.
The foundation for this library was laid by a computer scientist called Richard Karp who,
in 1972, showed 21 different problems to be NP complete,
and that was basically the starting point for this huge list of thousands of NP complete problems.
Now, let's see if you already have an intuition which NP complete problems
would be most useful to show the NP completeness of other problems.
So, let's say you encounter  a number of problems.
One problem will deal with clustering or finding large groups of related objects
or you would encounter a problem that deals with covering a set of object as efficiently as possible.
So, you have to select a few objects that is some way observed or--
no, covering is a good term other objects in the set
or you could encounter problem that in some way deals with optimizing pathways.
So, getting from one point to another point
but there are few constraints up here that you have to meet.
Here, you are trying to find clustered groups of related objects.
Finally, you could deal with a problem that is about diversification.
So, large groups of independent objects don't have anything to do with each other.
And finally, something else.
Now, you already know the five NP complete problems.
You know the shortest tour, you know vertex cover, you know SAT,
independent set, and clique.
Now, what I would like to know from you is if you encounter a problem
that basically arises in one of these five situations here
which of these problems here for which we know that they are NP complete
would be your best bet for proving
a problem that falls into one of these categories here is NP complete.
So, basically using this as a basis for a reduction.
So, these are numbered and you can enter your numbers
for the ones that you think match best in these circles here.